foreign
[Music]
okay so something to remember on
striking and you guys should know
it's much closer than most people that
train who don't Spar or fight and
realize
okay so for example Yoko manucci
is a great strike for in the clinch
because it allows you to keep your elbow
down
as opposed to the hook
is also a closed technique but your
elbows knocked down and just like a
elbow that is straight
this way
as opposed to up
is a lot better because if I miss it
didn't really cost me anything okay so
same thing oh I don't really lose my
cover Okay so
does not happen from way out there
okay
so uh as he's doing the strike
um let's look at the yin and yang
aspects of the strike itself
so it's as it's coming up is its Yin
phase because it is going
up and towards him
so that is where I first match with it
and see contact okay and then as it's
going down and forward
is when it has its young face which is
where I yield to it okay
so uh it's coming we'll just go put your
other like we'll take the steps out just
so you can see that okay so as time goes
up I seek connection already you see but
I'm not shoving it
I just seek connection
and then as it goes in this is where I
yield to it
[Music]
same thing go
this is not it so I'm moving towards it
as it's moving towards me that's a young
young class
and that just gets worse go ahead and do
this right
that just gets worse the more I move out
you see because now we have the nurse of
our greater mass and things okay
and that's not Aikido and that's just
it's easy to do and that's why people do
it okay
so again just looking
he goes up I see connection I follow it
and then I let it yield
uh
boom let it heal there's the other hand
elbow comes in
so it just says
this would be wrong
that's wrong too
that'll never happen because the strike
already went by you and you're not gonna
catch that Quest okay
so again
as it lifts I lift and I yield to catch
one more time
lift
yield catch
your other hand is already guarding you
and so when I heal in other words I
don't want it down here when I do all
this and then think it's going to catch
up
my other hand is going up you see it's
on the center line boom he touched me
and get your adhesion going and you're
in
so we'll look at this time
boom
boom here and here
so watch this hand now
okay he's coming in catch
hook around and now it's going into you
do that
catch
hook
not catch Factory
[Music]
now they said This Is Us losing some ear
we know that part but here when I yield
how do I get back to the Elbow it's the
exact same way he let it go and you
catch it going into you you see
that's exactly what this hand did
because
other time goes whoa catch
in contrast to the direction of trouble
otherwise you can't trap anything okay
I said this side is going to do the same
thing
here
boom it's a head
you see you got it it let it catch it
thank you
you're not so you're not chasing things
you're trapping things
trap trap right there's one trap you see
fool trial
you got it it runs into it
there you go
your movement is out
all that gets easier
because you created a angled deflection
or angle of incidence to the trapping
angle okay so up with him feel the
pressure
that's when you yield
[Music]
all right
Yin enter yields
land boom
[Music]